à l'île dernière ligne droite pour
Vincent et Tom avant d'éteindre la
tablette
sa coince
c'est fini non
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous allez
faire
une voix puissante une chevelure de
l'Yonne et sur scène une énergie sans
faille Tina Turner était une légende de
la musique la reine du rock n' roll elle
est morte hier chez elle en Suisse une
longue maladie à l'âge de 83 ans
je vis chaque chanson si vous écoutez
les paroles vous sentez bien qu'on ne
peut pas rester au micro et dire c'est
vous avez besoin de les jouer vous vous
transformez en actrice
Anderson c'est pas ça
il participe non je sais pas Tina Turner
a vendu 200 millions d'albums dans le
monde en 1988 son concert au Maracana de
Rio rassemble 180 000 personnes un
record l'entreprise Matel a même lancé
l'année dernière une poupée Barbie à son
effigie une des plus grandes artistes de
ses 50 dernières années tout simplement
pas du tout
non je suis de passage de toute façon
elle est décédée hier soir
[Rires]
toutes les boîtes on passait cette
chanson à une époque mais bon c'est fini
moi pour mon âge les boîtes de se
terminer merci merci d'avoir été avec
nous voilà on est là vous connaissez là
vous connaissez Afida Turner
plus Afida Turner que tu n'as rien
de la civilisation mais là je suis là
pour rendre hommage à la à l'icône Tina
Turner à ma belle-mère et puis continuer
continuer à respecter le nom de Hackett
inattner avec mes chansons avec mon
courage et les honorer parce que j'ai le
sentiment d'avoir été choisi par cette
famille et continuer la Legacy Turner
voilà et à Love You
alors non mais c'est pas fini
quel puce et travailler à la
postériorité ça veut dire que n'importe
qui dans 20 ans dans 30 ans dans 50 ans
c'est un coup de cœur c'est une évidence
ce texte oui parce que c'est tout ce que
je croyais déjà
qu'on pouvait mourir d'amour que la
chose essentielle de la vie c'était la
mort
l'amour reçu l'amour bafoué l'amour
piétiné l'amour attendu donc tout d'un
coup dans un synopsis tout était là la
passion est la fin tragique
des chanteurs
aussi Tom Hanks par exemple est en train
de se faire scanner parce que lui il se
dit que peut-être qu'il va pleuvoir
se déroule en Chine le mois dernier un
homme d'affaires reçoit un appel en
visio d'un ami qu'il connaît bien et qui
lui explique qu'il a besoin d'argent
très rapidement pour un dépôt de
garantie dans le cadre d'un appel
d'offre bref il a besoin d'une grosse
somme assez vite alors pour le dépanner
et bien le chef d'entreprise procède au
virement
570000 euros quand même mais quand il
renvoie un message pour confirmer et
bien son véritable ami lui ne semble pas
du tout être au courant de cette
histoire jeff a offert à Lorraine
Sanchez une bague de fiançailles de 2,5
millions de dollars et alors c'est elle
Loren Sanchez
ok on sait maintenant qu'Amazon a trouvé
un moyen de régler son problème avec les
emballages plastiques en réalité d'après
l'enquête l'arnaqueur aurait utilisé un
système d'intelligence artificielle pour
modifier son image et sa voix afin de se
faire passer pour l'ami de la victime et
ça a marché l'homme d'affaires raconte
que pendant l'appel vidéo il était
persuadé de parler à la personne qu'il
connaît bien quand il a compris qu'il
s'était fait avoir il a aussitôt prévu
la police un peu trop tard sa banque a
pu bloquer une partie de la somme mais
pas la totalité donc le manuel elle
pourra pas faire par exemple la cuisine
l'intelligence artificielle puisque
chaque GPT va être en train de créer une
gamme de robots les robots néo
qui vont incorporer
et bien nous allons d'abord nous
augmenter là je pense que tu as raison
on pourra relier
je pense que les autres
quand nos enfants vont arriver sur le
marché du travail on sera à GPT 30
des écoles parce qu'il s'est rendu
compte que ça faisait baisser le niveau
scolaire voilà
le diable oui Satan il est là non le
diable non
elle Diablo se priver d'écran quand on a
7 ans pourquoi c'est bien c'est bien
c'est bien pourquoi bah pour notre
cerveau si tu regardes le soir que ça tu
vas devenir fou si tu regardes beaucoup